the last word heard of April
she had just managed to talk her way
into the dark zone and was on the hunt
for Roger Koopman otherwise known as
Warren merchants through a series of
clues left behind by Koopman in the New
York collapse book April had managed to
figure out where Koopman has been hiding
or was this just another lead to a clue
that would seem to somewhere else
[Music]
[Music]
April spent the last few weeks getting
familiar with the dark zone she has
learned the layout of the land and found
the best places to hide an area this big
is impossible to keep locked down and
the JTF are constantly working on
closing new tunnels that are opened and
lead out of the quarantine zone because
of this April has identified there are a
number of ways to get out of the dark
zone she soon realizes that the place
she needs to go is in the worst parts of
the dark zone to the north she was
headed to 117 West 58th today was the
day she would finally visit this
location to find Koopman and get some
answers around the death of her husband
once at this location she came across a
room with a folding table they had a map
of Manhattan and with various notes
posted around there was a large
whiteboard with a list of names each
with coordinates written next to them
one of the names was hers she was in the
right place but will was Koopman it
seemed as if no one had been there for a
while April continued to move through
the building quietly when she reached
the third floor she noticed some open
doors and could hear the hum of
electrical equipment all of the clues
had led it to this moment clutching a
super 90 she entered the room and found
a man with grey hair sitting behind the
disc she finally found Rodger Koopman
April wasted no time in questioning
Koopman why her husband bill was killed
was he involved for the dollar flew and
how he knew that she would come and find
him Koopman went to work answering these
questions as if he'd been expecting them
for a long time he started from the
beginning explaining that he knew
Amherst was up to something in fact a
lot of people did
no one knew exactly what he was doing
just that something big was coming and
that a lot of people approved and some
of these people were prominent positions
of the government and military cupen had
to keep a low profile if he had said
anything he too would have been killed
like Bill so he wrote the New York
collapse book hoping that someone would
be interested enough to hunt down the
truth once he realized that April was on
the trail
he lived further clues to help like the
wanted poster Koopman went on to explain
what bill had been working on that he
was part of a team that was
experimenting with a new vaccine design
this came under the label of
broad-spectrum antibiotic to Jessica
candle ended up continuing Bill's work
and eventually developed the first
prototype she then seemed to design to
one of the last surviving labs in Ann
Arbor where they've since made a handful
of samples it was at that moment that
April decided she needed to make the
600-mile trip to Ann Arbor for the
possibility of finding out more about
the project the bill was working on they
had him killed
Koopman was hesitant to help her with
this impossible task but eventually
accepted that he wouldn't be able to
change her mind and that he should
assist anywhere he could he told her of
a group called the Riverside Templars
situated close to the Hudson River they
would be able to help her get across
kuben handed April a note to pass on to
the leader of the Templars and wished
her luck on a journey
as April approached the Hudson River she
knows that she was being followed three
men walked towards her upon closer
inspection they were all wearing similar
clothes not overly hostile a question
why she was walking through the area
these were members of the Riverside
Templars this group looked after the
area and were generally left alone by
the JTF April explained that she wanted
to see their leader and that she had a
letter for him they took her shotgun and
patted her down before taking her back
to their camp April Mick the leader who
was known as master and turned out to be
a retired colonel of the United States
Marines he read the letter from Koopman
and returned her weapons and belongings
promising that one of his men would get
her across the river
later that night through the cover of
rain and darkness while dodging jtf
patrols April in a guide managed to get
across the creek by climbing underneath
the railroad bridge this was the first
time in five months that she'd set foot
outside of Manhattan before her in her
guide parted ways she was given
instructions to make her way to the
Riverdale Yacht Club and meet a man
called Blake he would take her the rest
of the way when April met Blake
he took her across the Hudson River and
all the way up past Elbe knee where she
could take the Erie Canal to Buffalo
April traveled eight days on a barge
down the Erie Canal with a family of
four eventually ending up just outside
of Buffalo
she was now halfway to a destination in
Ann Arbor unable to travel through
Canada due to border lockdowns she would
have to continue around the southern
shore of Lake Erie towards Cleveland and
then north towards another however she
is convinced by a group of local sailors
to take a ship to Cleveland as there is
a hostile group but the Jamestown Aryans
who occupied the southern shoreline
April arrives in Cleveland and hits the
local jtf base which has been set up at
the football stadium at the entrance to
the stadium April speaks to one of the
armed guards and requests further
information on how to get to Ann Arbor
the Centurion forms a of areas she
should avoid and a safer path to Toledo
after filling up her water bottles she
turns away to make a start on a hundred
mile hike before she leaves she's
stopped by a division agent who
questions where she got a division
backpack in super 90 April goes on to
tell me that she took them from a dead
division agent who died rescuing her in
New York he checks up on his story and
confirms it to be true but warns her to
be careful not all division agents would
stop to ask as people wearing division
agent gear are usually responsible for
their deaths shoot first ask questions
later as a perfectly acceptable response
for a division agent as they are not
bound to the usual rules of combat after
thanking the agent April quickly made
her way out of there she came across
some men loading trucks and threw
offering them payment in the form of
tobacco that she was given by the family
on the barge she was able to secure a
ride on the back of the truck to Toledo
the truck driver dropped off April just
north of Toledo where she would continue
the rest of the way to Ann Arbor on foot
this rural area was quite different to
what we she was used to seeing over the
last five to six months people were out
working the fields getting on with life
while passing through a small town April
once again felt like she was being
followed she turned and raised a super
90 towards three men that were quickly
making their way towards her they called
out to her and told her to calm down but
at the same moment there were three more
men approaching it from behind
they were surrounding it April's spun
around and fired a shotgun taking one
down she ran north and they pursued
turning to fire the lust for shells she
found herself getting tackled from
behind but without hesitation
April drove a knife into the man's ribs
by the stage two of the men who'd
survived a shotgun fire had caught up
and were holding a gun but before they
could do anything April saw some
movement from behind them and she could
see the orange glow of an Isaac brick on
his backpack they were quickly
dispatched he introduced himself as I
cron sin' April thanks him for saving
her life and explained that she was
heading for another he decides to join
her for the remainder of her trip as he
has business to deal with there they
walked for more than forty miles to get
there by the end of the day being that
it was late and they were exhausted from
the day's hike they decided to get some
rest before visiting the labs in the
morning April felt strangely at ease
with this man he'd saved her life and
was a division agent so he was one of
the good guys right they found an old
rooftop cafe to spend the night
Ike set up a fire pit while April
dragged over an old couch April was
tired and was starting to fall asleep
but was discussing your journey with Ike
who was sitting in chair on the other
side of the fire when suddenly they both
heard footsteps
another man sporting the orange circular
glow of division agent appeared lit up
by the light of the fire the agent
introduced himself as array Leo Diaz he
said had been drawn to the area by
reports of the civilian wearing division
gear
April explained why she had the gear
going on to tell the story of how her a
knight met on the road to another it may
have been because she was tired or that
she just felt safe in the company of two
division agents but she went on to tell
them the full reason of why she was
making the journey and about the
broad-spectrum antivirals that were
being produced in the labs they were to
visit tomorrow
the next morning they head towards the
North Campus they met up with a
professor who confirmed that she has
worked in a team with Bill she went on
to tell them how shortly after the
outbreak officials placed priority on
keeping the facility secure so they
could continue their work the professor
tells them that they've managed to
create a batch composed of 24 doses of
the antivirals and that they have been
sent to an advisor of the president in
Washington DC it was at that moment that
agent Diaz received a call in his
earpiece and he went out into the hall
to answer it
while April continued to get answers to
a questions related to Koopman and her
husband a few minutes later
Diaz returned then casually he pivoted
towards Ike and knocked him out cold
with a left hook while tie him to a
chair he would go on to explain why DA's
tells April the full story that Ike was
an agent stationed in New York and he
left three days after April head under
orders from an unknown organization that
he's a double agent that he's gone rogue
he was under specific orders to find
April Diaz has been tracking him since
he abandoned civilians in New York
leaving them to die he also said that
the call he just received told him that
I could just ordered a strike on this
facility and that they will be here any
minute
this calls the professor to run from the
room so that she could inform the local
JTF who were guarding the compound Mike
started to come to he told of how he was
approached by a group how they confirmed
what he was already feeling at that time
that the JTF and government were
incapable of restoring order to the
country that it was time for someone
else to step in and fix things
it was about this time that they could
hear the sound of helicopters
approaching I quit on to say that they
better move fast a couple of weeks from
now they'll be seizing control of the
fuel supplies up and down the East Coast
dears thought about this where the
controls the fuel controls the vehicles
and all be the vehicles that would
decide the outcome of the upcoming war
leaving Ike tied to the chair Diaz and
April evacuated the building attempting
to find a way of escaping the facility
Diaz could see that the JTF had no
chance of holding off this attack they
were outnumbered and outgunned with
Blackhawks hovering around above they
managed to get away from the attackers
in a clearing outside of Ann Arbor
Diaz tells April that she must get to
Washington and find a division agent and
let them know what she has seen and that
the antivirals must be located
Diaz wouldn't be coming with her he
needed to visit the fuel facilities and
do everything he can to stop this
invading force from taking control
but before they parted ways he had one
request
he asks April if she's able to check up
on his two kids amelia and ivan who are
being looked after in the castle
sediment in d.c
as April got close to the castle
sediment she could hear the sound of
gunfire ahead of her April sees a group
of kids being approached by a group of
armed men they were pointing the guns
and shouting at them to stay put without
a second thought
April opened fire on the men given what
she had seen over the last few days she
wasn't going to take any chances these
were just kids what could they have
possibly done it was obvious that these
kids had something to do with the
fighting going on at the castle and that
these men have something to do with the
ones who were attacking it this was
enough for April to make the snap
decision to put him down her initial
burst dropped two of the men and the
others rent for cover
she's signaled for the kids to follow
her but at the same time more men were
advancing on them the kids ran past her
April told him to keep going while she
fired one last burst forcing them in
into cover
she then dropped her weapon and followed
behind the kids when April finally
caught up with them at the Washington
Monument she quickly fell to the ground
her pants leg was covered in blood but
although no one had followed them she
knew they couldn't stay there for long
they had to make their way to the main
JTF base of operations at the White
House before she hurried them along she
had to ask where any of these agent
Diaz's kids amelia and ivan raised their
hands
April told him that she'd been with
their dead and that he is safe but has
some business to take care of before he
could come back to Washington they made
their way to the South Lawn of the White
House April shouted out to the perimeter
guards saying that she has kids who need
help and that she's been shot they were
led into the grounds April collapsed
onto the grass and the kids gathered
around her she saw across the yard an
agent April yelled out that she has some
urgent information the agent was more
concerned about how she'd come across
the division gear she was wearing but
April refused to address this until the
kids have been taken to safety when the
agent returned she explained about the
division gear and went straight into the
information around the broad-spectrum
antibiotic WestEd during this time April
has been seen to by medical personnel
after a short moment to absorb the
information the agent called Kelso told
her that she can hang around for a while
so she can heal and get back on her feet
for the first time since the outbreak
April didn't have a particular place or
goal that she had to rush towards
her home was in New York but she
certainly didn't want to go back there
she had found out what had happened to
harassment and the impact he made
towards finding a cure for the dollar
flu she had the sense of calmness come
over her like she could finally after
all these months risked knowing that she
had played her part
this has been well overdue addition to
the April Kelleher videos that are
released about a year ago now in case
you haven't guessed it by now this story
is heavily based on the broken dawn
novel that is the sequel to the New York
collapse if you haven't read either of
these books I strongly urge you to
they're fantastic and they really go
into the detail of what happened and
what it was like during the early stages
of the outbreak it gives you insight
into the first person's perspectives of
a division agent and even an agent to a
drug effect I purposely only covered the
story from April's perspective because I
didn't want to skip over things even
more than I have in order to keep this
video to a reasonable length so I'm
thinking I might cover both Diaz's and
Ike's point of view in separate videos
let me know what you think if you want
to check out the books I mentioned above
I'll have a link to each of them in the
description and no I'm not getting paid
to say any this and I'm not meaning
anything through Amazon affiliate
marketing or anything like that I just
think they're a really cool addition to
the story anyway thank you very much for
watching I hope you've enjoyed this and
I'll catch you in the next one
Cheers
you